مرحبًا جيتا ، يجند فيسبا هو المعيار
صُنعت إندونيسيا لتكون متطرفة مثل
مثل ركوب فيسبا على هذا الطريق
نفخر به
نحن عائلة في فيسبا أصفر
هذا دم مختلف لكننا واحد
هذا المليون فيسبا البسيط هو إندونيسيا
ينتمي إلى الجميع مرة واحدة Bhojpuri لايف ستايل
لأنها كانت هواية لفترة طويلة
حتى الآن هو متطرف
هذه مدرسة ثانوية لأنها عادية للغاية
اركب فيسبا قياسيًا كما تريد
خلق المزيد من التطرف
هذا غريب هاه
مراجعة الطور البيني للاستوديو القوي بشكل أفضل
من الاختيار الأمثل للكتاب
كرسيول تانجونج ، التعديل ، أليس كذلك؟
الخطوات الأولى للاتصال
جسم فيسبا يريد صنع عجلات
من ناحية أخرى ، كم يمكن أن تكون Unisba لدينا؟
العجلة 10 11 أم لا آلة اللحام
الاستمرار في جعله يدرس نفسه بنفسه أولاً في
Extreme Bass Brothers أو مجموعات صغيرة
الناس حياة أفضل وعمل OTG الثلاثة
الهاتف العام قطعة واحدة اندونيسيا المشجعين
أوه نعم ، آخر دراجتي النارية تريد أن تُرى
سأطلب مثل هذا في الواقع
الحدث نعم أريد أن أنام هذه دراجتك النارية
لا يمكنك lutra ما الفراء ، دعنا نذهب
ارفعونا هنا معًا اركبوا
المحرك بعد السلس سيعمل من أجل أ
تغيير نشعر جميعا اندونيسيا
انه جميل
أوه نعم كما لو كنا على الطريق
قابل الشاطئ أو جبال جانغ يانغ
الكتاب لم يعرف ذلك من قبل ، أليس كذلك؟
أشعر أننا أغرب أجمل بهذه الطريقة
الصحيح
واو واو